This story is just the height of the full
logical conclusion to Donald Trump continuing
to hold his rallies with no regard whatsoever
for the attendees public health.
This doesn't even have to do with coronavirus.
Donald Trump did three rallies yesterday.
The third was in Omaha, Nebraska, at roughly
9:00 p.m. Eastern Time.
I covered it live.
It was sort of cold.
And there's also a pandemic going on now just
based on the pandemic.
Before I get to the cold, this was a bad idea.
Just looking at cases in Nebraska, the curve
is spiking.
It's not good.
It's a terrible idea to continue holding these
rallies.
This one was packed with reportedly 6000 people
shoulder to shoulder, very few masks.
Even the people on stage behind Trump widely
not wearing masks.
Trump said there were twenty nine thousand
people there.
That was a lie.
But there were 6000 people.
And that's way too many for when you have
a global hundred year pandemic.
But that's the case at every rally.
Last night there was the added humiliation
for Donald Trump, which was that it was cold.
And Donald Trump wrapped up quickly, actually,
one of the shortest rallies he's given in
this campaign yesterday because it was cold.
And Trump flew out on Air Force One, too.
I think it was wherever he was overnighting,
maybe Las Vegas or something like that.
The temperature dropped to nearly freezing.
Rally goers started lining up to get their
bus rides back to their parking lots for miles
away.
But the busses weren't there.
The busses couldn't get in because outbound
traffic from the airport where they held the
rally occupied both the inbound and the outbound
lanes.
All traffic was going out, busses couldn't
get in.
And for hours, attendees, including older
folks, just stood there.
Police had no idea what to do.
Some groups started walking miles on the sides
of the road.
I mean, it became almost post apocalyptic.
And then the hypothermia.
Nine one one calls started.
People were stranded.
Police were saying we need 30 busses here
now.
Can you imagine?
And if you look at the tweets, monitoring
the Ohmar, the Omaha police scanner, you start
seeing reports of medics treating parties,
police requesting incident command to put
people in a warehouse because people are freezing.
We need more medics.
We have one medic treating four people.
Calls flying in about elderly folks needing
assistance.
Eight to nine elderly people struggling elderly
party unable to move with altered mental status.
Elderly male down Trump by continuing to hold
these ego boosting rallies.
His ego created a dystopian post apocalyptic
scenario.
I actually recently read a really great novel
called Station Eleven.
It's by Canadian author, I believe, Emily
St. John Mandel.
And it is actually a post pandemic dystopian
novel.
And there are exactly these scenes people
walking miles into or out of airports with
no transportation in the book.
It's because there's no more fuel here.
It's a different scenario.
This is what Trump created last night with
his ill advised rally, all to feed his ego.
And when I saw this, I thought to myself,
you know, the only reason we have low temperatures
is because we have so many thermometers, if
we could.
We're only finding freezing temperatures because
we keep checking the temperature with a thermometer.
You know where I'm going with that?
Anyway, as I've said before, these rallies
don't convince people.
If you are so deluded and out there to even
go to one of these rallies during a 100 year
pandemic, you're voting for Trump regardless.
And this is all about feeding Donald Trump's
ego.
And just imagine devoting yourself to any
one person the way these people have devoted
themselves to Trump, never mind to somebody
who is actually like Donald Trump, who couldn't
care less about all of these people.
Now, if we do our jobs.
These rallies end forever in six days.
If we don't, then these rallies probably continue
and slide directly into Trump doing rallies
for, who knows, maybe one of his kids.
Who will run for the Republican nomination
in 2024, so there's a lot riding on the next
six days.
Let's keep it going.
Let's do the right thing.
Early voting numbers look good, but the polling
among those still waiting to vote look good
for Trump.
So let's not assume anything at all in any
state.
Keep it going.
Let me know how voting is going in your state
and your town in your precinct.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break.
And we have
so
much more to discuss today.